un grand nombre de sociétés financières
qui promettent à leurs investisseurs de
mettre leur épargne au service du climat
finance des entreprises polluantes c'est
ce que révèle une enquête menée par un
consortium de médias européennes qui
montrent que près de la moitié des fonds
étudiés investissent dans des actifs
liés à l'industrie fossile Corinne
Gendron un professeur au Département de
stratégie responsabilité sociale et
environnementale de l'UQAM bonsoir alors
comment on explique que des fonds qui se
disent Verts se disent durable se disent
responsables investissent dans des
sociétés comme la pétrolière totale par
exemple mais c'est que en fait il y a
plusieurs stratégies pour faire des
investissements qu'on appelle vert on
peut avoir la stratégie de filtre donc
on exclut des secteurs entiers mais on
peut aussi avoir la stratégie qu'on
appelle les meilleurs de la classe donc
best of class à ce moment là on va
choisir des entreprises qui certes
polluent mais qui dans le secteur montre
une bonne performance financière donc
fond peut être vert ou durable mais
investir dans des pétrolières oui si la
pétrolière a démontré qu'elle faisait
des efforts suffisants maintenant on
peut se questionner si ce qu'on appelle
effort suffisant correspond pour le fond
à la même chose que pour le consommateur
ou pour l'investisseur et l'enquête qui
a fait le consortium de médias dont le
journal Le Monde en France il y a
plusieurs journaux qui ont participé à
ça qui ont regardé des centaines de
fonds est-ce que le constat est étonnant
le conseil est étonnant et pas parce
qu'en fait c'est en vertu d'une nouvelle
réglementation européenne on a créé des
catégories pour faire un peu le ménage
dans tout ce qui est fond vert fond
responsables etc on a voulu donc faire
des catégories alors on a ce qu'on
appelle l'article 8 et l'article 9 donc
l'article 8 c'est tous les fonds qui se
revendiquent des fonds qu'on appelle ESG
donc des investissements des entreprises
qui vont tenir compte des critères
environnementaux sociaux et de bonnes
gouvernance pour donc pour choisir les
investissements et puis on a l'article 9
ça c'est un article où on veut aller un
peu plus loin on dit
ce sera seulement les entreprises qui
contribuent aux objectifs de
développement durable qui sont les
entreprises dans lesquelles on va
investir et là ce que l'enquête a révélé
c'est que cet article 9
disons qu'il y a des fois on
investissement qui se revendiquent de
cet article 9 alors que dans le
portefeuille il y a des pétrolières et
on dit bah écoutez les pétrolières ne
peuvent pas se sont pas des entreprises
qui contribuent au développement durable
donc elle ne devrait pas faire partie de
ce qu'on appelle la catégorie
verte foncée
mais est-ce que est-ce qu'on comprend
que c'est que ces fonds là viennent
bafouer un peu l'intérêt des
actionnaires ou est-ce que c'est une
interprétation que les sociétés
financières font de ce de cette
réglementation jusqu'à dire qu'ils vont
les bafouer c'est qu'il y a toutes
sortes de problèmes techniques pour
mettre en place cette nouvelle façon de
de catégoriser les investissements et
notamment il y a pas de méthodologie
reconnue on est encore en train de
travailler là-dessus donc bien sûr il y
a des divergences il le fait que les
fonds quand même ont des impératifs
financiers traditionnels il faut qu'ils
continuent à se diversifier donc c'est
difficile pour eux de laisser
complètement aller tout le secteur
pétrolier même s'ils veulent se
revendiquer comme étant vert et d'un
autre côté il y a les pétroliers aussi
qui veulent absolument accéder à ce
genre de label si on veut parce que ça
leur donne d'une part une bonne image
publique et ça montre au public qu'ils
font des efforts en matière de
changement climatique même si il font
partie du secteur pétrolier et c'est là
qu'on se demande nous comme investisseur
si c'est pas de l'écho blanchiment du
greenwashi absolument et puis je pense
que là il faut vraiment se questionner
sur comment est-ce qu'on va concrétiser
cet article 9 parce que si on dit qu'une
entreprise signe une pétrolière par
exemple continue ou termine si on veut
des sites d'exploitation ça peut à la
rigueur s'excuser mais quand on parle
d'entreprise qui démarre de nouveaux
projets qui font de la prospection là
c'est un peu difficile de dire que c'est
compatible avec l'article 9 du nouveau
règlement européen comment on peut
rendre ça plus transparent comment on
peut améliorer la réglementation
l'information également pour que les
gens les investisseurs comprennent bien
ce qu'il y a dans ces forces mais en
fait la réglementation actuelle la
réglementation européenne va dans le
sens là c'est de rendre ça plus
transparent parce qu'il y a avant il y
avait plein de fonds c'était un peu le
Far West plein de fonds qui se disaient
responsable ou durable mais on n'avait
pas le cahier des charges pour chaque
terminologie donc la réglementation qui
vient qui a été adoptée en 2021 vient
clarifier ces catégories là mais elle va
être complétée par des exigences de de
clarification de méthodologie notamment
sur quel genre d'impact est-ce que
l'entreprise a sur l'environnement puis
on parle d'un nouveau critère qui
s'appelle le critère de double
matérialité c'est à dire qu'est-ce que
l'entreprise
quels sont les risques environnementaux
et sociaux qui paient sur l'entreprise
mais aussi quels sont les risques que
l'entreprise fait peser sur la société
donc c'est ce nouveau critère de double
matérialité qui va commencer à guider
plusieurs des normes du secteur
financier est-ce que fondamentalement on
n'est pas rendu à l'étape du point de
vue des investisseurs en tout cas où il
faut des investir de ces sociétés plutôt
que d'y aller avec l'accompagnement pour
améliorer leur pratique c'est vraiment
une excellente question je pense que le
désinvestissement aura sûrement un
impact par ailleurs il y a des
innovations qui peuvent se faire qui
doivent se faire j'ai pas de réponse
disons complètement tranché là-dessus
mais je pense qu'actuellement
malheureusement on est quand même encore
en train de financer des choses qu'on ne
devrait pas financer et je ne parle pas
seulement des investisseurs privés je
parle aussi des gouvernements qui
continuent à subventionner les énergies
fossiles on en revient pas ils font
d'une main ce qu'ils interdisent de
faire de affaire de l'autre donc et nous
comme investisseur aussi canadien
québécois on est loin d'avoir le début
du commencement de toutes les
informations qu'on a par rapport à
l'Europe effectivement donc au Canada
aussi il y a des des opérations de
clarification qui vont venir
je suis moins au fait là des derniers
des derniers avancements mais ce sont
des choses qui sont réfléchies parce que
les investissements qu'on appelle ESG ou
du rame responsable ont vraiment le vent
en poupe et les consommateurs veulent
avoir des règles plus claires Corinne
Gendron c'est très intéressant merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir
analysé tout cela merci merci pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]